nous traversons une crise majeure et
notamment une crise climatique est-ce
que le philosophe a un rôle à jouer
là-dedans et si oui lequel
oui le philosophe a un rôle à jouer je
crois pour aider à
appliquer le problème
c'est un peu
c'est une tâche effectivement qui peut
paraître un peu ingratte mais qui est
nécessaire parce que en fait le vrai
problème avec les problèmes c'est qu'en
général on en prend pas la mesure
et prendre la mesure de ce problème là
qu'on appelle le réchauffement
climatique c'est essentiel parce que si
on n'arrive pas à y répondre depuis
quand même 50 ans c'est parce que
justement on en prend pas la mesure on
voit pas la mesure de la quantité de
changement
ça implique de faire face un phénomène
comme le réchauffement climatique
et donc la philosophie en général qu'est
ce qu'elle fait au fond elle nous dit
que nous devons changer des catégories
fondamentales de penser des évidences en
fait vraiment de l'autre des choses qui
sont de l'ordre de l'évidence pour
pouvoir répondre à un problème donc
prendre la mesure d'un problème ça veut
dire prendre la mesure de tout ce qu'il
faut changer dans nos évidences les plus
immédiates pour pouvoir être à la
hauteur de ce problème et en
l'occurrence moi mon idée est assez
simple c'est que enfin simple c'est de
comprendre en fait que le réchauffement
climatique nous oblige à repenser ce que
ça veut dire au fond exister parce qu'on
avait tendance à penser que exister ça
voulait dire être une réalité matérielle
et que sur cette réalité matérielle
était apparue des vivants que c'est
vivant était devenu des êtres conscients
et que ces êtres conscients étaient
devenus être humain enfin etc etc or je
pense justement que il faut repenser
complètement ce que ça veut dire exister
à partir de la notion de terrestre alors
on va expliquer peut-être que veut dire
terrestre en tout cas sous votre plume
puisque la terre n'est pas ni
l'habitacle ni une planète parmi
d'autres mais bien quelque chose d'assez
singulier en tout cas un concept oui
justement ça désigne pas simplement une
chose parmi d'autres c'est pas
simplement des habitants qui se trouve
sur une planète qui est localisée dans
un système solaire lui-même dans
l'univers Thérèse ça désigne une
certaine manière en fait de se produire
de produire sa propre réalité et ce qui
caractérise les Terrestres c'est que au
fond ce sont les terrestres qui ont
fabriqué la terre qui est elle-même la
condition de possibilité de leur
existence
si l'atmosphère dans lequel nous vivons
est vivable c'est parce qu'il y a des
vivants en l'occurrence des bactéries
qui ont oxygéné cette planète donc les
terrestres ont fabriqué la terre le fait
qui est tant d'oxygène dans l'atmosphère
terrestre et pas du tout une donnée
astronomique c'est une conséquence de
l'activité des vivants sur la terre donc
la terre c'est quelque chose qui est une
relation entre ces habitants et ces
conditions d'habitabilité et en fait ce
qu'on appelle le rechargement climatique
n'est que un cas particulier d'un
ensemble d'autres phénomènes parmi
lesquels il faut quand même dire
l'effondrement de la biodiversité dans
lesquelles justement des terrestres
mettent en danger l'habitabilité même de
la terre donc la crise a convoqué une
nouvelle forme de philosophie oui je
pense que effectivement aujourd'hui on
peut plus se contenter de l'idée selon
laquelle on a d'un côté la nature par
exemple et d'un autre côté la culture
que la nature serait donc cet espace
préalable en fait aux habitants
et que la culture viendrait par dessus
en vérité on se rend compte aujourd'hui
que tout ça est mêlé et au fond la
notion de terre et quelque chose qui
nous permet de comprendre que cette
réalité là et bien est consubstantielle
au fait qu'il y a une planète habitable
une planète encore une fois habitable
est rendue habitable par ses habitants
et donc aussi elle peut être rendue
inhabitable par ses habitants donc c'est
les habitants ont la responsabilité
d'une certaine manière de l'habitabilité
même de leur planète tout entière et ce
qui est propre alors on pourrait dire ok
mais ça c'est vrai d'une ville c'est
vrai d'un quartier c'est vrai d'un pays
etc sauf que on peut toujours se
déplacer à la surface de la Terre en
revanche sortir d'une planète alors ça
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pourquoi
est-ce qu'on demande pas aux
scientifiques ou aux responsables
politiques de tenir ce type de discours
est-ce que la philosophie encore un rôle
à jouer particulier une valeur ajoutée
ou quelque chose voilà de magnifique par
rapport aux autres types de discours
oui parce que elle seule d'une certaine
manière par exemple nous permet de
comprendre que l'idée même du savoir
doit être modifié en fait dans un tel
dans un tel contexte parce que l'image
qu'on avait traditionnellement du savoir
c'est des êtres humains qui produisent
des représentations mentales sur une
réalité qui les précède et qui d'une
certaine manière est indifférente à ce
monde alors là on voit bien que la
notion de terrestre réalité c'est un mot
que j'ai un peu inventé mais je crois
quand même qu'il est facile à mettre en
usage la notion de terrestre réalité
nous montre qu'en fait on peut pas
penser les choses comme ça puisque on
est nous-mêmes déjà impliqué à l'un dans
cet environnement donc la notion
d'anthropocène qui est désormais assez
populaire désigne bien ça désigne bien
le fait que on ne vit pas sur une
planète qui est indifférente on vit sur
une planète qui en fait réagit je dis
toujours on danse avec la terre la terre
est un acteur avec laquelle on doit agir
bon et ça ça met en cause des intuitions
c'est élémentaire
bon ça c'est une donc vraiment une
première réponse une autre réponse c'est
que si on aborde en fait ces questions
une question comme le réchauffement
climatique
il y a beaucoup de raisons pour
lesquelles on n'a pas été capable lors
des cinq ans dernière année c'est long
quand même un demi siècle de se tenir à
la hauteur de ce problème mais une des
raisons c'est probablement qu'on a
abordé d'une manière beaucoup trop
technocratique comme s'il suffisait
simplement de trouver des solutions
techniques à un problème technique or là
on se rend compte qu'en fait c'est
l'idée même de techniques où je dirais
presque l'idée même d'une action sur le
monde qui doit être modifié et justement
il faut rompre avec cette idée sont à
laquelle il y a d'un côté les agents
nous qui avons la puissance de
transformer la réalité et de l'autre
côté cette réalité un peu passive parce
que en fait cette réalité n'est pas
passive elle réagit bon on l'a vu avec
la pandémie de covid-19 ce que ça
voulait dire parce que en fait c'est les
virus on peut croire que c'est dans la
nature mais non c'est pas dans la nature
en fait parce que ils sont dans des
souvent dans des réservoirs par exemple
dans des chauves-souris et si ces
chauves-souris viennent contaminer
d'autres espaces c'est parce qu'en fait
on détruit leurs habitats donc en fait
la pandémie de covid-19 est un effet de
l'anthropocène est une manifestation
presque un symbole de l'anthropocène
donc on est dans un monde qui ne cesse
de réagir et ça vous voyez bien même
l'idée de science doit être modifié par
rapport à ça l'idée technique doit être
modifiée par rapport à ça au fond c'est
vraiment toute une civilisation qui doit
repenser ce que ça veut dire être au
monde en fait
une civilisation qui
qui va nous contraindre sans doute à
changer aussi la définition de ce qu'on
appelle l'homme alors je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait de Michel Foucault
c'est dans une émission de 1976 et après
d'y réagir à partir d'un certain moment
qu'on peut situer
entre la fin du 16e siècle et le début
du 19e il s'est passé un phénomène
important tout de même c'est que l'homme
a cessé d'être immédiatement dominé par
les grandes menaces de la mort c'est à
dire par les menaces des épidémies des
familles les formidables ravages de la
mortalité infantile et que l'homme en
quelque sorte disposé les sociétés
humaines je parle uniquement d'ailleurs
de l'Occident mais c'est là où les
choses se sont nouées que les sociétés
occidentales ont commencé à disposer
d'une espèce de marge de survie
à partir duquel l'homme est devenu
relativement disponible par rapport à
ces urgences fondamentales ou à ces
grandes menaces de la mort qui avait
traversé son histoire jusque-là et alors
c'est à partir de ce moment-là qu'il a
fallu en quelque sorte à la fois utilisé
et mettre en question essayer de
problématiser
l'homme en tant qu'il pouvait être
disponible d'où la question qu'est-ce
qu'on va en faire comment l'appliquer
appliquer cet individu et bien à la
croissance des forces productives
comment les discipliner comment
construire des grands corps politiques
etc et je crois qu'on a eu là toute une
technologie de l'homme qui s'est
développée à partir de ce moment-là qui
est la question de l'homme est-ce que
cette question sera
du RA autant que l'humanité peut-être
pas peut-être pas
est-ce que la question de l'homme durera
autant que l'humanité
au courant parce que c'est très frappant
dans ce que dit ici Foucault c'est
effectivement les sociétés occidentales
ont acquis une sorte de marge de
manœuvre or ce qui est arrivé avec
justement les ruchements climatique
entre possède qui ne pouvait pas
anticiper il faut bien le dire mais
c'est justement que cette marge a
disparu en fait ce que la pandémie par
exemple à manifesté c'est justement le
retour de problématique qu'on imaginait
des problématiques archaïques et on voit
très bien que Foucault au fond il décrit
quoi ici il décrit la modernité il écrit
une certaine idée de modernité c'est à
ça en fait que on ne peut plus croire le
cas des antibiotiques est vraiment
frappant parce que avec les
antibiotiques on avait le sentiment
qu'on allait se débarrasser des maladies
infectieuses on avait un petit peu entre
guillemets oubliés parce que il y a
quand même plein de gens qui l'avaient
pas oublier l'antibio résistance et
c'est un exemple typique de la réaction
des êtres soi-disant naturels aux êtres
soi-disant culturels et en vérité c'est
une du fait que ces êtres ne sont pas
partagés en deux en fait ils sont
mélangés les uns avec les autres de
sorte que on ne peut pas séparer d'un
côté l'humanité d'un autre côté tout le
reste en fait
reste du monde c'est égal la pandémie
est une occasion presque plus qu'elle
était le mode Bruno Latour sur lesquels
vous avez écrit un livre le philosophe
la terre et le virus le virus a été une
sorte d'expérimentation à grande échelle
finalement et de confirmation en quelque
sorte de sa philosophie ce qui fait que
Bruno Latour est intéressant c'est
justement qu'il a essayé de proposer une
description de ce dont Foucault parle
c'est-à-dire de la modernité qui la
remette un peu sur terre et qui cesse de
croire qu'il y a eu cette sorte de
grande rupture
civilisationnel dans lequel soudain les
êtres humains ce serait arraché alors
conditions terrestre en réalité ils ont
inventé un mode d'habiter la terre qui
est un mode non viable donc ce que la
tour proposait de faire c'est simplement
de décrire en fait la manière
dont c'est moderne habite réellement la
terre donc le rôle d'un intellectuel je
pense quand même c'est effectivement de
construire des problèmes et il faut bien
dire que la tour a été assez
visionnaire en fait de ce point de vue
là il a vu que là il y avait un problème
et qu'il fallait repenser autrement nous
remettre sur terre et j'étais frappé
dans le petit extrait de Foucault où il
se reprend à un moment il dit les
sociétés humaines enfin je ne parle que
de société occidentales bien c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire que la
modernité est une manière d'habiter la
terre une manière de se terrestrialiser
projeter dans la terre
qui en fait est à la fois très local
elle commence en Europe bon ça s'étend
sur le continent américain et par le
biais de la colonisation elle devient
globale sauf que en fait elle va être
divisée spatialement entre ces sociétés
européennes ou disons euro américaine ou
japonaise
qui profite d'une certaine manière ou
qui peuvent avoir le sentiment que les
limites planétaires sont longues et les
sociétés colonisées qui elles n'ont pas
du tout cette expérience et qui vivent
en fait l'extraction des ressources de
la manière la plus dure qu'il soit
approche dis ça je pense que les
minéraux européens ont vécu
l'extractivisme de manière assez dure
dans leur corps mais donc il y a un
différentiel comme ça et c'est sûr que
les pour qui on est des salles de bains
et des hôpitaux qui nous permettent
effectivement de sentir que la mort
s’éloigne ben en fait il faut que
ailleurs sur cette terre il y ait des
puissances très violentes en fait qui
s'exerce donc c'est cette la qualité si
vous voulez de la condition de la
terrestrialité moderne qui explique que
ce mode de vie que ce soit développé
sans avoir à prendre en compte sa propre
en fait non viabilité terrestre or
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
mais avec la globalisation avec la
décolonisation la promesse de la
modernité en fait a été étendue à
l'ensemble de mondes et là on se rend
compte qu'on n'a pas la place et donc il
faut commencer à négocier il faut
commencer à discuter et donc climatique
est une question géopolitique exactement
c'est parfait on arrive à la politique
c'est sans doute l'un des points central
de votre livre et également de la
réflexion de Bruno Latour je propose de
regarder cette image l'Arbre Monde
justement où tout est relié ou
finalement c'est un peu une philosophie
de l'interaction à l'intérieur de
laquelle précisément cette question de
l'homme ou du sujet enfin qui est donc
un concept irrité surtout du 17e siècle
n'a plus vraiment lieu d'aide si l'homme
n'est plus cet acteur politique comment
on va repenser la politique comment on
va repenser les catégories du par
exemple pour nos Latour ne parle plus de
classes sociales mais de géoclasses
est-ce que vous pourriez revenir sur sur
ces nouvelles catégories avec lesquelles
nous allons devoir penser le politique
mais l'action politique également
oui ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
pour aborder justement ces questions il
faut pas se contenter de d'avoir une
seule image du terrestre du global et
l'arme au monde ne doit pas devenir ne
doit pas remplacer en quelque sorte dans
la position de vision hégémonique l'idée
disons de nature opposé à celle de
culture justement ouvrir le champ des
négociations c'est accepter qu'il y en a
plusieurs en fait des représentations de
ceux qui nous rassemblent je dirais dans
la même Moïse quoi parce que c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'on est tous ensemble
dans la même Moïse et que pour l'instant
comme disait militants il y a pas de
planètes B quoi donc c'est ce que veut
dire en fait cette unité donc la
première chose à faire c'est d'essayer
de rouvrir l'espace des négociations
sachant que de toute manière on n'a pas
tellement le choix parce que il y a des
grandes puissances impériales comme la
Chine par exemple qui ont bien
l'intention de faire ça il y en a
d'autres qui n'ont pas cette force
impériale comme par exemple les
yanomanies du Brésil dans la forêt
amazonienne qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'imposer par la force en fait leur
propre vision mais justement je crois
que notre responsabilité à nous c'est de
dire bon ben ouvrons ouvrons cet espace
et essayons de discuter ensemble en
étant réaliste aussi puisque malgré tous
les rapports de force compte et donc
c'est là où effectivement la question
c'est quels sont les alliés sur qui on
peut s'appuyer et si on se content de la
notion de de classe sociale ben on n'a
pas les bons indicateurs en fait pour
savoir comment est-ce qu'on va mener ce
vaste combat parce que c'est un combat
pour disons faire revenir le mode de
production moderne dans les limites
terrestres
ça il y a des il y a des il y a des
intérêts qui sont contraires à ce projet
d'une certaine manière était élu sur ce
sur ce programme et il est pas le seul
il y a beaucoup de aussi d'hypocrisie en
fait y compris dans notre pays sur cette
sur la le sérieux avec lequel on prend
en compte en fait le projet disons de
ré-étrialisation de faire rentrer en
fait dans les limites planétaires et là
il y a une lutte à mener et donc la
question c'est qui sont les alliés et en
fait on sait pas très bien qui sont les
alliés pour l'instant et donc la notion
de classe géosociale est une manière
justement de dire bon bah il faut il
faut trouver en fait qui sont les
véritables alliés de même que le
mouvement social mouvement ouvrier le
socialisme et le communisme ont fait un
énorme travail pour construire une
notion disons de classe c'est à dire des
collectifs en lutte qui se reconnaissent
dans un même projet
la même manière il faut faire ça et on
n'a pas beaucoup de temps pour le faire
ça c'est la différence parce que les
socialistes avaient 100 ans on fait ça
sur 100 ans et nous on a pris pas mal de
retard sur cette tâche et dans cette
tâche là bon ben il y a des humains mais
il y a aussi des non-humains je pense
que il faut faire alliance avec les
abeilles
ont des intérêts
communs avec celles et ceux parmi nous
qui pensent effectivement qu'il faut
aller contre certains intérêts
et cette division par ailleurs passe à
l'intérieur de chacun d'entre nous c'est
à dire
bon est-ce que faut manger de la viande
pas manger de la viande prendre l'avion
pas prendre l'avion sachant que de toute
manière
chaque activité qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui dans le monde tel qu'il est
contribue et au réchauffement climatique
et à l'effondrement de la biodiversité
et à l'expansion dès lors que chacun de
nos actes contribue à la crise
climatique si deux faits en achetant des
céréales le matin ou en mangeant un
burger on participe de ce réchauffement
climatique comment arriver à se sentir
néanmoins une certaine forme de pouvoir
de capacité d'action bon je pense de
toute manière que
il faut commencer par se dire qu'on a
pas le choix c'est-à-dire qu'on a une
responsabilité ici qui est équivalente
moi je suis frappé à celle qu'on vécu
les gens on va dire au moment de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
la guerre est quelque chose qui a fait
effraction dans les vies individuelles
de telle sorte que la sortie de la
guerre c'est pas par hasard si quelqu'un
comme ça entre créer une revue comme les
temps modernes et développe ce thème de
l'engagement pour dire il y a plus de il
y a plus d'extériorités on peut plus se
retirer en fait aujourd'hui il faudrait
convaincre en fait qu'on est dans une
situation très similaire donc c'est la
première chose à faire et bon la
deuxième chose c'est simplement
s'informer et aussi militer pour que on
dispose des outils par exemple les
céréales quelles céréales et il faut
arrêter de croire qu'il y a des grandes
réponses un peu globales en fait c'est
tout un travail de discernement c'est un
grain de perception c'est ça qui est
magnifique c'est-à-dire qu'on va être
plus précis
végétarien et le fait d'être végétarien
ça ne m'a pas disons enlevé quelque
chose ça m'a ouvert un degré de
précision dans le rapport de mon corps
de mes saveurs de mon goût de ma manière
d'être au monde avec le monde dans
lequel je vivais donc c'est c'est
quelque chose assez heureux du point de
vue sensible je dirais mais là il faut
demander aux institutions parce que on
n'a pas toujours les moyens de
s'informer et là je voudrais insister
sur une chose c'est à dire que on oppose
souvent les petits gestes du quotidien
avec les grandes obligations imposées
par l'État moi je crois pas du tout qui
soit opposé plus on s'interdira de
prendre l'avion ou on décidera de si
l'on renoncer complètement en tout cas
de réduire drastiquement la viande etc
plus on sentira la nécessité
en fait de ce qu'on appellerait un
rationnement c'est là encore ça c'est
proche quand même de la guerre parce que
je crois qu'aujourd'hui l'heure est au
rationnement donc il faut effectivement
repenser la la manière dont les
différentes parties de la population
humaine et non humaine s'accapare en
quelque sorte les choses c'est pas
encore une fois un appauvrissement c'est
à dire que
c'est le temps qu'on trouve d'autres
manières de créer par exemple de
l'énergie
peut-être qu'il y aura une autre manière
de temps qu'on se remette un petit peu
dans ses limites planétaires
et de toute manière si on le fait pas le
l'avenir c'est celui de Lans sauvagement
du monde c'est celui de de conflits
extrêmement violents dont on a vu avec
l'invasion de l'Ukraine un exemple en
réalité de conflits extrêmement violent
ou de toute manière rationnement il y
aura quoi qu'il arrive simplement il
sera fait dans la précipitation de
manière très injuste sans discernement
au sens fort du Maud discernement
discerner ça veut dire sentir les
différences et c'est très beau de sentir
différent de sentir la différence ça
veut dire être plus riche perceptivement
plus on perçoit les différences plus on
est riche en vérité il y a pas d'autres
richesses ça s'apprend ça ça s'enseigne
bah je moi ce qui me fera plutôt c'est
le fait que du point de vue pédagogique
le travail a été fait y compris dans le
point de vue scolaire les écoles et on
voit très bien que les jeunes ont été
formés en fait à cette perception
aujourd'hui je crois que l'heure est
venue de l'institution c'est pas c'est
plus le moment de la mobilisation
collective de la transformation des cons
bien sûr il faut continuer comme ça mais
je suis même des fois tenté de me dire
bon
il faut faire une grève en fait d'une
certaine manière des petits gestes pour
que les gouvernements comprennent que la
balle est dans leur camp nous on est
prêt nous on est prêt je crois bien sûr
tout le monde ne l'est pas mais plus les
gouvernements répondront à cet appel
plus il y aura de gens qui sont bien sûr
si ils le font de manière juste en fait
s'ils le font d'une manière qui
n'exacerbe pas les inégalités et ça
c'est un truc qui est parfaitement
démontré même dans les sciences sociales
et dans les gens qui travaillent sur les
questions du climat c'est-à-dire qui il
n'y a pas de transition écologique
possible dans le cas de dans un contexte
d'inégalité si on fait ça de manière
brusque et injuste ça ne marche pas donc
c'est une question d'efficacité
aujourd'hui le la justice sociale n'est
pas un luxe la justice sociale est une
nécessité terrestre absolument vitale
bon et encore une fois moi je dis
toujours la question n'est pas de savoir
si la Terre va continuer ou pas la
question de savoir quelle terre vous
voulez est-ce que vous voulez d'une
terre dévastée avec des de guerre de
tous les côtés ou est-ce que vous voulez
d'une terre effectivement un petit peu
plus multiple parce que il y a plein de
terre possible et le GIEC lui-même
définit différents types de scénarios
donc nous notre travail c'est d'essayer
de mettre à disposition des gens des
outils qui leur permettent de comprendre
finalement dans quelle terre ils sont en
train de se projeter aujourd'hui en
achetant leur céréales dans le
supermarché quelle terre est envoyée
vers l'avenir et ça c'est un travail
effectivement qu'il faut faire au cas
par cas c'est à dire au niveau de
l'agriculture au niveau de
l'architecture au niveau même militaire
donc tout ça en fait d'une certaine
manière doit être capable de même que
c'est capable si vous voulez d'être
monétisés on sait combien ça coûte ben
il faudrait savoir en fait quelle terre
ça produit
alors quel est le rôle du philosophe
dans tout cela est-ce qu'il est roi
ermite ou le conseiller du prince
moi je pense c'est le diplomate
c'est le diplomate mais alors c'est un
diplomate qui qui confondent on pourrait
dire des cosmologies justement comme
celle de l'arbre au monde comme celle au
contraire de d'une terre qui serait
uniquement faite de ressources qu'on
pourrait extraire de ces sous-sols de
son sol d'une terre qui serait celle de
par exemple comme il y en a dans les
mondes qu'on appelle aborigènes
australien qui est une désert est très
vivant
il y a différentes figures de la terre
et je crois que le rôle du philosophe
est justement de faire dialoguer d'une
certaine manière ces visions là
donc c'est c'est sûr que son s'attache
et je dirais aussi s'attache est une
tâche de mobilisation donner du courage
donner du courage pour penser et donner
le désir de penser faire sentir la joie
qu'il y a à penser vérité vous renouer
avec le mot d'ordre des lumières
absolument les trois livres de
philosophie qui vous ont construit
il y a des tics de Spinoza la joie de
pensée
il y a
un livre un grand livre de fondateurs
des sciences humaines qui s'appelle le
Cours de linguistique générale de
ferdinandes Saussure parce que il
introduit au fond la notion de structure
même si le nom est pas et pas prononcé
exactement et pourquoi c'est important
la structure en fait c'est important
parce que la manière dont les bistrots
cela reprendra nous permet de comprendre
si vous voulez que une structure en fait
c'est quelque chose qui est articule des
variantes les unes avec les autres et
qui nous permet de ne pas avoir à
choisir entre le fait qu'il y a de la
pluralité le fait qu'il y a de l'unité
et ça pour moi c'est absolument vital
aujourd'hui pour comprendre que on est
tous et toutes ensemble dans une même
entité enfin tout juste dans une entité
qui n'est pas forcément la même pour
tout le monde mais différente mais que
cohérentes et elle est cohérente
présentement parce que les variantes les
différences s'articulent les unes aux
autres dans ce qu'on pourrait appeler
une structure donc moi j'ai une théorie
de la terre structure qui vient
directement d'une certaine manière de
chaussures
et peut-être le troisième je dirais
c'est Mille Plateaux de legoatari
peut-être à mon avis le plus grand livre
du XXe siècle vraiment ouais pour moi
c'est vraiment ce livre de l'autre côté
parce que c'est un livre qui prendra
encore des décennies si on les a pour
être vraiment compris
c'est sûr on peut passer on peut partir
sur une île déserte avec ce livre si on
a un peu de culture philosophique
les mots de Sartre comme je l'ai dit
pour moi Sartre en fait une figure qui
est qui est très sous-estimée en
particulier en France et ce livre est un
livre d'une très grande beauté
stylistique
qu'il a mis 20 ans à écrire et qui par
ailleurs me touche parce que non pas du
tout que je viens du même milieu que lui
mais ce que j'aime beaucoup chez ça
entre c'est qu'il a il a pas peur de sa
propre bêtise
et il a défini un jour l'intellectuel
comme quelqu'un qui se mêle de ce qui ne
le regarde pas et en disant ça il
voulait dire non pas parce que ce qui
chose qui nous regarde pas en même temps
sont très importantes mais il disait
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui ne se sent
jamais à sa place là où il est il dit
même c'est un produit loupé c'est
quelqu'un qui est jamais des biens et
dans les mots au fond il décrit
c'est l'histoire d'un raté c'est la
généalogie d'un raté et se rater là et
ben c'est la condition même en fait
d'une certaine manière de l'intégrer
parce que comme il est pas bien il fait
bouger les choses d'un endroit à l'autre
il est diplomate le rôle de la
transmission
essentiel ou je suis professeur d'une
part mais aussi je dirais il faut
transmettre ce qu'on voit du futur
aujourd'hui présent
et pas simplement dans l'autre sens il
faut que et aujourd'hui on peut quand
même avoir un certain nombre d'images
sur le futur et on voit bien que c'est
frappant aujourd'hui un des grands
travaillent de la pédagogie y compris à
l'école vraiment presque primaire et de
nous dire quels sont les futurs
s'il fallait n'en garder qu'une quelle
est la grande question philosophique
aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'être terrestres
c'est ça qui va nous permettre de
repenser tout la question du savoir la
question de l'existence la question de
la politique la question de l'action la
question de l'individuation l'action du
corps tout peut être repensé à partir de
cette question qu'est-ce que c'est que
la terrestre réalité
merci